amid the lockdowns across europe nature
goes on it is tulip season in the
netherlands and the colours are
mesmerizing but look a little closer and
you can see a problem these are flowers
that nobody wants there are no weddings
no restaurants open
no florists to buy them on his tulip
farm hank is focusing now on selling
bulbs rather than cut flowers but the
price has Harvard and his profits have
simply dried up
you're always thinking is it going to
kill my company when you are facing
every day new flowers they have to go
back and go away they sell them and if
they didn't say oh yeah you have to
throw them away so it's costs your money
across this part of Holland you see
field after field of uncut tulips and
that's not a good sign what coronavirus
will have huge economic consequences and
this is a pretty good early warning
system because the market for tulips has
collapsed and that has knock-on effects
for farmers and distributors and
shopkeepers and what's happening today
to these flowers is going to be mirrored
in all sorts of industrial sectors in
the weeks and months to come
in northern France dairy farmer Pierre
Villiers is wondering how he'll cope his
family have been making cheese here for
a hundred and seventy years they've
dealt with big problems in the past but
the present is tough restaurants and
markets all closed in this room alone
there's 30,000 euros worth of cheese
slowly going off it will all be thrown
away
he's got 80 cows here Pierre has already
had to dump more than 20,000 litres of
milk enough to keep a small village
going for a year all of it poured down
the drain
last time we were unable to sell on a
similar level it is during the Second
World War when the German occupation
prevented open markets I've never seen
it like this most new Germany we do find
a glint of optimism in the sunshine this
pick-your-own farm is selling produce
pretty much as soon as it's ripe
customers here get the bonus of exercise
and fresh air but this is a grim time
for farmers Europe single market has
just about closed down that will
frighten many Adam Parsons Sky News
northern France